that's a good number all right there we
go that's way way higher than usual I'd
love to see that progress for those of
you who don't know who we are T spring
is an entrepreneurial platform we allow
people to bring products and launched
brands in the market without cost risk
or compromise so in 2014 as Sam
mentioned we shipped over 7 million
products one in 50 Americans bought a
teespring product and more exciting for
us 20 people became millionaires on the
service hundreds made six figures and
thousands now make a living and so what
we're aiming to do is change the way
that people think about what it takes to
go from idea to product in the market by
essentially removing things like
manufacturing logistics customer service
everything that we kind of consider that
that we can abstract but when I think
back to three years ago when this was
really just in idea too crazy college
students in Providence Rhode Island had
that everybody we asked thought was
stupid and I think how we got that
initial traction and momentum and sort
of what were the biggest contributing
factors to it it really comes down to
the fact that we did whatever it took
but put more eloquently we did things
that did not scale we didn't plan for
the millionth user on day one all we
focused on was the next order of
magnitude and so you know as a startup
you have a lot of disadvantages versus
larger companies and competitors you
don't have as many people you don't have
nearly as much money you don't really
know what your product is even gonna be
in 12 months it's not as feature-rich
there's all these disadvantages but
there's one significant advantage
enormous advantage that people massively
discount and that is that you can do
things that don't scale and I define
doing things that don't scale as growth
strategies that are fundamentally
unsustainable that will break at a
certain point and normally they break
around founders not having enough time
in the day sometimes they break around
profitability you know it costs a
certain amount of money and the more you
scale the more that money caught the
more it costs the more you lose but
fundamentally they just will not take
you to the millionth user and I'm here
to argue that this is the largest
advantage that you have as a new company
and the more that your company grows and
you start to see these competitors come
out and move really fast be more agile
than you're able to be the more you'll
realize how valuable this was in the
early days there's three places that I
recommend that you maximize this
advantage that's recruiting early users
and when I say early users it doesn't
have to be the first ten users we used
the same strategies to recruit users up
until we were doing millions of dollars
a month in sales to turn those early
users into champions every great product
has champions their fundamental to
building a great company and then
finally finding product and market fit
so how you can use this agility and
being able to do things that don't scale
in the early days to figure out what
your product even should look like and
should be so recruiting early users I
always have to start out by saying that
there are no silver bullets in user
acquisition or in the vast vast majority
of cases there are not and what I mean
by that is that it's it's human nature
that when you launch you want to look
for that easy path to success and and
from the outside looking in at a lot of
companies and I hear this when people
look at teespring and it looks like an
up into the right curve it seems like it
was so simple that something just went
in a fire start and it went so you look
for a similar strategy as a business you
look for an SEM strategy you're gonna
pay five bucks you're gonna make ten
dollars it's gonna grow and you're gonna
be a huge business overnight you look
for having a sort of viral loop and
every user brings in two users it's just
going to explode
but for the vast vast majority of us and
for every great company that I've had
the chance to speak to the founder of
the reality is that getting the first
users will take a significant amount of
time and effort and that's from early
employees and founders and that can mean
a lot of different things for us it was
you know I I prefer to be in the realm
of design user experience and so this
act of sort of hustling was sort of
foreign to me and it was a transition
for me to realize that the most
successful thing that I could do to grow
our business was not to focus down on
incrementally improving the product but
rather get on the phone in every single
day I would try to make as many calls as
possible within a four hour span before
I ever got into Photoshop or anything or
started coding or anything else that I
could look at but that spending that
time is just absolutely fundamental and
it comes down to the fact of you don't
want to focus on ROI for your first
users you want to focus on growth by any
means possible and I visualized this
bike if you think of like a perfect Hill
and you're trying to push a boulder up
that hill the first couple steps the
incline is the steepest it's the hardest
you're pushing as hard as you can it
takes time and then over time you get
its things smooth out a little bit and
you keep pushing you keep pushing and
eventually you reach the peak and the
boulder starts rolling on its own but it
is gonna be hard work to get that
movement started and to reach that peak
so in the early days of teespring
I think any investor anyone looking in
would have thought it was a miserable
business we launched in the first
clients we went after were local
nonprofits and it was taking weeks of
meetings you know iteration after
iteration of designs we were driving
back and forth dropping off samples when
orders did come in we would have to
actually go and call the printer and
manually organize all the details it was
hundreds of man-hours for every hundred
t-shirts sold so we would make $1000 for
probably a hundred hours of work which
again seemed entirely unsustainable and
we heard a lot from investors early but
for us the most important thing
was giving our users a fantastic
experience and making sure that every
single person that touched our service
walked away happy so that if they heard
the name teespring they would be an
advocate and one of the one of the great
things about this is it's sort of a
necessity to grow that you give this
White Glove service so Paul Graham who
it was the founder of Y Combinator but
also at a company called via Web which
eventually became Yahoo stores in the
early days very similar to teespring
they built this sort of do-it-yourself
store builder technology launched it
only to realize that nobody was going to
give him the time of day to actually use
the product so it ended up that their
team they would have to go out and sort
of consulting ask go to these people and
say hey we'll just build it for you
we'll use our own technology just tell
us what you want and we'll do it all for
you and giving that White Glove service
it's almost demeaning to an extent
because you puts your heart and soul
into this product and yet here are
people saying it's just not worth my
time can you just do it for me but at
the end of the day that White Glove
service breeds champions and champions
are for me sort of the lifeblood of a
great company a great example of going
the extra mile to recruit those early
users is reddit so in the early days
Alexis and Steve when they wanted to
have these meaningful discussions and
yet there just were no users on the site
so when new users came in who are they
going to talk to and so they actually
went out and created dozens of fake user
accounts and fake personalities and had
the decide like debates between
themselves on every single link which
seems crazy but now they're spending all
this time actually using their own
service but now a new user comes in and
here's the thoughtful debate that they
were looking for and it bred these users
that were champions and up to a certain
scale where eventually they didn't have
to be there anymore the users were
engaging with what they had seeded
astroturfing there you go so the the
next big thing is it's turning users
into champions and what I mean by a
champion is a user who not only uses the
product or as a customer but is also
advocating for
you know talking about your product to
other users or other potential users I
should say and this is a fundamental
part of building great companies I have
a something I tell people who are just
getting started which is you want to
build a painkiller not a vitamin you
want a product that doesn't a vitamin
incrementally improves your day it's
certainly valuable but if you go a week
without your vitamin you're not really
gonna notice a significant drop-off in
quality of life now if you need
painkillers and you miss a painkiller
for a day your your whole quality of
life shifts so you want to build a
product that people fall in love with
and one way and and need and one way to
build up that sort of product is to
engage the early users in the most
white-glove service where the founder is
reaching out asking them how it's going
getting their feedback hearing their
suggestions go to where your your
competitors cannot with that personal
level of service and at the end of the
day it's about delighting users with
experiences they'll remember memorable
experiences and the easiest way to do
that is to simply talk to your users and
I know this is something that you hear
all the time it's sort of a maxim of
startups it's a tenant of Y Combinator
it's everybody says talk to users talk
to users and yet when I go in and I and
I look at early companies oftentimes
while they know they should be talking
to users there's a difference in in
theory and reality and it's usually
because in the early days of a company
things are not perfect right
fundamentally if you're moving as fast
as you should be your product is gonna
be a little bit broken a little bit
wonky there's gonna be things missing
and sometimes talking to users is
painful because they tell you what
you're missing and they say ah you know
I'm gonna I got to leave because you
don't have these things or it keeps
breaking or whatever it might be but
talking to users is the best way to
build a meaningful feedback loop and
understand where the pain points are you
need to get good at filtering out sort
of noise versus signal but this is still
today every single night when I get home
I spend 3
for hours looking through every Facebook
community that talks about T Springs all
these amazing entrepreneurial
communities of people discussing
strategy I read every single tweet about
teespring
good and bad and there are absolutely
bad and try to make it right I give
every single user my email address so
that when they have a problem or they
hear a buyer writes them an email and
says hey I got a shirt there was a
splotch on it or the design was the it
was slightly off-center whatever it
might be they can email me directly so I
can deal with it and getting that
feedback loop is fundamental so three
ways you should be focusing on talking
to your users one handle your own
customer service this is it's it's this
is kind of a this is a unique one for me
because there's nothing else there's no
other service I use in in my entire life
where even today so I haven't done
custom I do customer service tickets but
I don't handle it exclusively now every
single time I open up our customer
service portal I get a visceral like
sinking feeling in my stomach from those
early days where we I would open it up
and I was so committed to trying to
build something that people loved and so
focused on trying to putting everything
I had into this product and yet you'd
open it up and you'd hear about these
experiences that are totally contrary to
what you're aiming for somebody bought
products that were supposed to get there
for a birthday and they were late
somebody got a bad print something they
didn't like it never showed up but we
handle Evan my co-founder and I handled
customer service all the way until the
point where we were doing two hundred
three hundred thousand dollars a month
in sales and and I think that those
early experiences helped guide us to the
company we are today we look nothing
like the the company that launched and
it was listening to users and
understanding where we missed and also
making sure that we experienced the pain
of the negative side of the business of
the mistakes we were making so that we
were even more committed to making them
right the second is to proactively reach
out to current insurance customers and I
call this one out because it's a mistake
that we made in in the pursuit of growth
you know there's so much like 30 40
percent month-over-month growth
same target it's it's it's ridiculous
for a business to have that sort of
growth and in pursuit of that oftentimes
you start to forget about your current
customers you you're you're so eager to
bring the next person in that you forget
to look back and say hey how are you
doing now that you've been with us for
three months or six months and the same
thing for churned customers it was years
before we started realizing and tracking
and reaching out to people who tapered
off or stopped using our service and yet
a simple conversation just reaching out
and say how are things going we're
reaching out to a customer who stopped
using the service and saying hey I I saw
you I saw you cancelled I saw you left
did something go wrong is there
something that we could talk through I
love the feedback that can be the
difference between a user walking away
and building a user who knows that it's
gonna get better who's gonna work with
you who's gonna give you feedback
towards improving who becomes
emotionally invested it's time out of
your day and there's a million things
that that you need to be spending time
on but it's that small touch that can
build champions so listening in via
social media and communities this
depends on what kind of company you are
but I would define that more as trying
to listen in to third party streams of
communication so anything where people
don't really know that you're listening
because then you can see this kind of
unfiltered stream of feedback and in any
way you can and so again that goes back
I'm OCD about reading every comment
every post every tweet about teespring
and they're even the bad ones and then
you know there's emails that go to team
at teespring calm angry emails so so a
really good example of a company that
that went the extra mile to build
champions is Airbnb so in the early days
of Airbnb this behemoth this amazing
company they were struggling it was a
ridiculous figure they're struggling to
get any traction and get off the ground
and so what they did is first they went
to New York City where their users were
and they did two things one they started
hosting meetups with this very small
community buying people drinks going to
bars learning what people were actually
thinking saying and wanted from the
experience and then when they heard from
custom
who were renting Airbnb 'is that the
quality of the photos and the listings
weren't exactly exactly giving them
confidence that they could sort of that
this was something they wanted to do
they went out and hired professional
photographers and professional writers
to go out there and actually make each
of the listings beautiful so that it did
inspire that early confidence and got
those early users now is it sustainable
to have to fly a professional
photographer out to each apartment
listing and have them sort of
professionally for tech professionally
shoot it as well as do having a writer
review the listing absolutely not but it
got them those first few feet up that
hill and then the boulder kept rolling
and the problems are inevitable in a
startup it's just by a nature of the
fact that you're building a new company
problems happen every single day at
teespring there are things breaking
there are customers that have bad
experiences it's not so much whether you
do have problems it's what you what you
do when they come and how you react in
the early days of teespring we made a
conscious decision that we were going to
do everything we possibly could to not
let people walk away with a bad
experience and it there were points
where you know again in in the very
early days that money is not unlimited
you are absolutely you can't really
afford to do it we had users where we'd
ship something out and the color would
be a little bit off or the size would be
a little bit wrong or there'd be just
something slightly wrong and your
inclination is to say well it's you know
it's almost there like it should be fine
sometimes this was like half a month of
gmv and we just could not afford to lose
it but we had made that decision and in
all of those early cases we would go and
we would either completely replace or
completely refund every single order on
the purchase and a side effect of this
is we made it so painful to make
mistakes that when a mistake did happen
the whole company sort of rallied
together and made sure we put practices
into place that it wouldn't happen again
so the last thing I want to talk about
is finding product and market fit and I
know hustle con is is more focused on
folks that are non Technic
but this absolutely applies to you as
well so the product you launch with will
almost certainly not be the product that
finds market fit and what I mean by that
is you need to wiggle your way into
finding what your company will look like
what your customer base is going to be
what features you're going to need
whether you need something that's robust
and handles power users or really simple
to handle a great funnel and have
novices have a great experience
you're not going to launch with a
perfect picture of what the company will
become and so in in knowing and
accepting that your job is to make sure
that you stay as agile as possible so
that you can find what will be your
company as you grow and it comes down to
the fact you need to iterate as quickly
as possible to find fit and so as an
example in the early days of teespring
we were going after these small
nonprofits and then there were these
kind of big behemoths of companies and
nonprofits that came in and said hey
you've got something interesting here
we'd like to use it but you know we have
teams and and branding requirements and
all of these things that need to be
better handled for us to do this and I
sat down with Evan and we looked at it
and we said well we can do this but if
we build this the right way it's gonna
take a month and a month doesn't seem
like a lot of time but in startups
you're sort of living in dog years a
month is a ridiculous amount of time for
anything and so instead of actually
building the future out the right way
what we did is duplicated the code-based
duplicated the database hacked the
ugliest code you'll ever see just to
make it work put it out to those
enterprise users and we did it in four
days and within a month we found that
those weren't going to be the right
customer for us at that time and we were
able just to completely sunset the
product and we didn't have to worry
about it didn't impact the core product
we didn't burn a month and we figured
out very quickly the profile of who our
users would be so optimized feet for
speed over building scalable technology
again this is your baby you're putting
your heart and soul into this product
you want to build it the right way you
want to build it the way you picture it
in your head but the reality is it's far
more important to get something out
there listen to the users and use growth
as a compass
when you feel users pulling you in a
direction you can move towards it's
called hill climbing and and it really
is I would say one of the reasons we're
here our user base today which are
entrepreneurs who come up with ideas and
brands influencers like youtubers who
use teespring to monetize people use
Facebook advertising Twitter advertising
Pinterest ads now we had no concept that
those would be successful users we
thought it was college kids and
nonprofits and had we launched with a
product that was fully optimized for
those verticals I wouldn't be standing
here today and I don't think this
company would exist and so for us that
take that lesson of MVP to the extreme
and anytime you want to try something or
you want to build something always think
about the fact of how do I get this done
as quickly as humanly possible so that I
can find out if it's right for us or if
it's not right pivoted again a great
example of stripe so we use stripe I'm
sure a lot of you guys use stripe for
those of you that are accepting payments
stripe in the very early days when they
were trying to figure out what they
needed they had this API that looked
beautiful and literally every single
transaction that came in there was
somebody who was on the phone calling
the transaction and there was no
interface layer between orders actually
being accepted in the service and
placing those orders out so a huge
company that started with sort of the
man behind the curtain strategy of why
go and build the the transaction the
automation layer when we're just trying
to figure out what our users want a rule
of thumb is to only worry about the next
order of magnitude so when you have 100
users worried about what the company
looks like can it survive to a thousand
a thousand ten thousand and so on and so
forth if you're worrying about the
millionth user and their experience and
how your technology is going to scale
when you have a hundred users you're
you're pointed in the wrong direction
and the sort of my belief anyway is that
you'll survive if if your company does
so well and users fall in love with and
you hit those traction points and you
grow the
way that you want to grow and the
technology starts to break or crumble or
server start to crash and I'll give some
examples of this you'll find a way to
survive I call those like quote-unquote
rich people problems you know if you're
able to actually get there deal with
those problems when they emerge don't
try to solve for something that doesn't
exist now because again you'll end up
building beautiful scalable technology
with a product that people don't want
and so some some sort of notable
examples everybody remembers the fail
whale Twitter had a nightmare of a time
scaling but because they had built a
product and found traction their users
stuck with it and less than notable
example is teespring so we followed the
lessons of MVP and agility and don't
worry about technical debt and lots of
duct-tape code to an extreme degree and
for almost a year during when we really
sort of caught fire and started to grow
quickly we couldn't really push out any
features because we were so in the weeds
of firefighting and trying to scale
there was about a six month period where
teespring would crash every single day
and we would all go to sleep with our
phones on and like under the pillow and
every single night all of our phones
would go off and you'd you know wake up
and lumber over and restart the database
but you know what it was worth it and
what I have if I could go back what I
have built the technology the right way
the first time no because I would have
built the wrong technology so don't
worry about what happens when you hit
that millionth user worry about how
you're gonna find growth and market fit
so again doing things that don't scale
is is a fundamental advantage you have
and it's something again I will argue is
one of the biggest advantages that small
companies have you can provide a level
of service and you can have a level of
agility that larger companies cannot and
that allows you to outperform them small
teams can run circles around big teams
and it's something that we deal with
today now looking at smaller companies
and competitors where the speed that we
want to move at they're able to be more
flexible because they're dealing with
several there
much smaller user bases so don't give it
up until you were absolutely forced to
even today I do lots of things that
don't scale there are positions where
you need to make trade-offs you know I
was the catch-all email address for a
long time until it started to take like
4 hours a day at teespring and so I had
to give that up but don't don't get to a
point where you find that initial
traction and throw away the lessons that
got you there continue to speak to
customers continue to be as agile as
possible with your technology relish the
advantage that you have and one day when
when you guys find when you grow to the
size that that that you're looking for
and become the companies you're looking
for you'll look back on this and wish
you still had that agility so thank you
guys so much I appreciate the time and
looking for asking us questions
thanks Walker we'll take one question so
I was wondering you're talking about
kind of a pivot point if things aren't
really scaling too well or just not
going on when do you throw in the towel
sure it's a really hard choice so I had
a company before teespring
where we ran into that where you know
you have to make well I'll take an
example from teespring so when when you
release products if you're talking to
all of the users especially first you
should follow users to the products you
should build use growth as a compass I'm
a fundamental believer in that
philosophy allow users to pull you
towards what you need to build throwing
in the towel is really when you find
that the complexity you know either
people demand it for free huge no-no or
people demand customization in every
single implementation that was what we
found with the enterprise but a lot of
it comes down to instinct you know I
think that starting a company there's a
lot of points at which you need to sort
of roll the dice and go off of your
instinct there's points during the first
year where I absolutely thought and
looking back it looks you know it looks
smooth it looks easy but there were
points in that first year where I
absolutely thought about hey maybe this
company won't won't make it maybe this
isn't a business model that works and we
considered throwing in the towel and
that same thing for enterprise so I
think it's an instinct call you have to
see how the customers are reacting and
make a decision about whether or not
that's actually going to be a viable
vertical all right thank you so much
guys appreciate it